- Hello Believe Nation.
I started the Mentor Me series
to try to hang around people
who've done a lot more than us.
And hopefully by spending a
little bit more time with them
some of how they think, their values
their beliefs, their
mindsets, their attitudes
seeps into us to help us become
the best versions of ourselves.
So today we're going to
learn from Grant Cardone
and some of his best motivation.
Mentor me Grant.
Rule number nine is my personal favorite.
And I'd love to know which
one you guys liked the best.
And as always guys as you're watching
if you hear something that
really resonates with you
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
And when you write it down
it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(triumphant music)
- Dude that's not a normal
state, that's lazy okay?
That's not normal to be putting
your head down on a table
and not be moving, snap, and pop.
To not be adding wood to your fire.
Look, lazy as I wrote
in this recent article
that was read by almost
four million people
with I think as of
today, 14 thousand likes
and just as many dislikes
even people rageful and angry.
Maybe you're getting like that right now
about my article.
That lazy is the new entitlement.
Look, just see if this describes you
or anyone you know.
I only do enough.
I make as little as possible.
I save as little as possible.
I invest as little as possible.
I learn as little as possible.
And hey, I work as little as possible.
And when my five days
are over with each week
I have to, I must take
Saturdays and Sundays off.
I'm entitled to it.
These are the policies of the lazy.
And they're ruining our country.
They're ruining anyone that
operates with them okay?
Normal, a normal state is not lazy.
A lazy person is actually educated
encouraged, acknowledged,
and it's allowed.
Lazy is an allowed state in organizations.
So if you see anybody in your group
in your organization, in
your family that's lazy.
Hey! Knock it off man!
It don't work.
You end up with too little money
not enough love, not enough work
and not enough customers.
Lazy is a failed policy.
And I'm here to wake you up about it.
Look, if you want to be in
business for yourself and free
you must learn to dominate.
You cannot compete okay?
How many were trained this?
Competition is a healthy thing.
That message was not being
delivered to entrepreneurs.
That message was being
delivered to consumers.
There was somebody saying,
"Look the more oil companies
"We have, the better because
it's good for the customer."
Right?
That the more technology companies we have
it's not just Microsoft,
the better for the customer.
And inventions and you know,
improvements in products
comes from competition.
But if you're the one playing the game
you want to dominate the field.
So look, here's the deal.
I might be wrong in what I say okay?
I might be wrong in the
things I do in my life
and the business that I started.
My family's told me not
to start every business
that I've been involved in.
Every one of them.
Every one of them was a risk.
Every one of them I had to take a chance.
I remember my mom used to tell me
"I wouldn't do that if I were you.
"I wouldn't do that if I were you."
I'm like, "Mom, you wouldn't do anything."
(audience laughs)
You wouldn't do anything
except be the mother.
A great mother to five children.
My mother wasn't an entrepreneur.
She didn't have my dreams.
Just because she's my mom
doesn't mean she dreams like me.
Would you agree?
Okay, my mom was wrong
about everything she told me
not to do.
I love my mom to death.
Okay, unbelievable friend
of mine. She was wrong.
I needed to do those things okay?
Steve Jobs needed to build this phone.
Would you agree?
Did he help a lot of people?
Did he make some money
while he was doing it?
119 billion dollars in five years.
In the bank, cash.
I'm not talking about profit,
I'm talking about done.
In the bank, sitting there.
Okay, brings a great
product to the market place.
Domination or competition?
Total domination.
Coca Cola, competition or domination?
Total domination okay?
Exxon, total domination.
You see what I'm saying?
You want to be in a dominating point okay?
So what we've got to do is
we've got to get you thinking.
We've got to get you thinking
like the dominators think.
How do they act?
How does Warren Buffet act?
What does Warren Buffet do
with his time all the time?
Those are the people I study today.
I don't study the people
that I went to school with.
The teachers I went to school with.
I don't even study my own family members.
Okay, I'm looking for
people that are way up here
that I can say, hey what are they doing?
Because they're doing it right.
If you know what day it is.
You are not busy enough.
I recently heard this week
"Oh it's Monday man, it's
so hard to get started
"On a Monday."
I'm like, "Dude, how do
you even know it's Monday?"
I don't know what day it is.
On Wednesday we hear, "It's humpback day.
"We're halfway there."
So it's Friday and it's like
Oh, thank God it's Friday or follow Friday
or like, dude how do you
people know what day it is?
You're not busy enough.
You need to be so freaking busy
that you don't know what time it is.
You don't know if it's before lunch
after lunch, before dinner, after dinner.
Come on, you've had those productive days.
Remember the day when
you were so productive
you literally worked
through lunch and dinner
and you looked up at seven o'clock.
You should have been home an hour ago
and you're like, dude I
haven't had lunch or dinner.
You know why?
Because that day you were
eating the marketplace.
You were consuming the marketplace
because you were active, productive.
Hitting it, slamming, creative
and completely committed.
Look, that's where you need to be today.
Look, I don't know what Monday,
Wednesday, or Friday are.
I don't know about Saturdays and Sundays.
I know this.
Create tremendous amounts of activity.
So much activity that
you lose track of time.
Your success is not going
to come from watching TV.
Or looking at a calendar.
Your success is going
to come from activity.
From being busy, from being obsessed.
From being like, so into it
that you don't know about, oh my gosh
it's the Monday morning blues.
Or Wednesday humpback or Friday what?
I don't know, Friday what, whatever!
Okay, get busy.
The biggest struggle man
was just getting around
other people that would say I could do it.
I mean, that's the biggest struggle.
Just you get around one guy that says
"Yeah you can do it."
And then you talk to him tomorrow
and he's like, "No dude, it's freaking.
"You can't do this (beep)."
You know, there's so few
people telling you to do it.
You know what there is a lot of?
Save your money, protect
yourself, conserve.
Don't spend, don't take risks.
Taking risk is the new
way to be risk adverse.
So, the biggest struggle for me
was my family man.
The people closest to me
was the biggest struggle.
Every time I went out to do another deal
everybody told me, "You
don't need to do that man."
The only person that was encouraging me
was my twin brother.
Because I would see how he was doing it.
Dude, he was making his swings.
And so every time I would
get around other people.
So I'll tell you a little trick I did.
On weekends, I would always go see homes
I couldn't afford.
That has always inspired me.
I would go look, I would
go drive neighborhoods.
Literally, I've done this my entire life
until I finally got to the point
where they wouldn't even
let me in the neighborhood.
There's neighborhoods in
Miami you can't even go see.
They won't even let you in the gates.
Most of them you can get in if you know
some of my tricks.
(chuckles)
So the point that Shovida's
writing on the board right now
is you've got fuel in your tank.
It wants to be accelerated on.
And then you got somebody in the backseat
saying, "Hey be careful!"
Nobody likes a backseat driver okay?
So they're sitting there,
they're putting mental
pressure on the breaks
when you're trying to accelerate.
I use every one of the news channels.
You'll see me on TV
doing news one day okay?
I don't watch news, I make news.
See the shift?
You see the slight shift?
Don't watch the news.
Decide when you leave here
today to make the news.
Right?
You don't read the newspaper.
You write newspaper articles.
You don't read books, yeah read them
but learn to write them.
And you know, you don't
need to take forever.
You don't need to spend a
lifetime writing a book.
This was three hours.
Okay, we sold 40,000
copies of this one book
and it was self published.
It's never, ever, ever
been in a book store.
A guy writes me and he says
"Man, you've got misspelled
words all in that book."
(audience laughs)
I'm like, "Yeah, so
what? So where are they?"
"123, 128, 134, 165, 120."
I'm like, "Yeah, yeah."
"And bad grammar too."
I'm like, "Yeah, what's your point dude?"
(audience laughs)
"What's your point? Why do
you keep telling me that?"
He's like, "Because man
you've got misspelled words
"In a book."
It's a best seller (beep).
(audience laughs and applauds)
Okay, so it aint best written okay?
You know what and this word, (beep)
just so nobody understands,
I don't want you to think
that that's a cuss word.
(audience laughs)
The word (beep) look
it up in the dictionary
means a complainer, a
whiner, and excuse maker.
I wear a little band on my pen here.
On my wrist here, it's a little black band
and it says, "Champions dominate."
And on the other side
"Don't be a little (beep)".
(audience laughs)
That's right.
Because I don't need it.
I need to get rid of the
whiners, the excuse makers.
"Oh my God it's the market."
It's the market oh my God!
Prices, oh inventory!
Okay, now how much you got there?
It's too much inventory,
now too little inventory.
Human beings have so many
excuses it's unbelievable.
You know why?
Because you watch the news too much.
Because you've agreed to receive news
not make news.
The thing is not to just be positive.
Not even to offer this
no negativity policy
that I talk about.
The way to avoid negative
and distracting people
is to vibrate at a rate so fast okay?
That you're out in front of them.
Once I got a speeding ticket.
Actually here in Miami,
and the police officer says
"Why you speeding? Why
you in such a hurry?"
I'm like, "Dude I'm trying to
stay away from the crazies."
Okay, if I can just get
ahead of everybody else
I'm not distracted by
anybody but guys like you.
And your job is to stop me
but the truth is, their job
it to stop me, distract me
and cause me to turn around
and stop my mission.
See, so I got my ticket and moved on
and went to the head of the pack again.
See, this is what I'm telling you man.
Look, if you want to not be bogged down
by negative distractive people
you need to take responsibility
that you're slowing down enough
to get caught up by this magnetic charge
of distractive and negative people.
Dude, you need to vibrate so fast
that these people are distracting
other people, not you.
Get way ahead of the crowd.
Get so busy that nobody's
going to jack with you man
because you're filling up your pipeline.
You're full, you're busy
and you don't have this
stuff sticking to you.
Over and over, almost
every seminar I go to
somebody will walk up to me and say
"Dude, how do you handle burnout?"
And my reply is fast and simple.
"I don't believe in burnout."
That's right, I don't believe in burnout.
Now, I know if you're experiencing
the exhaustion that is associated
with this idea of burnout
that nobody can prove by the way.
That this seems impossible to you
that burnout doesn't exist.
But I'm telling you, listen to me.
Burnout is not real, it's made up.
Take a step back for just a second
while I try to sell you on this idea.
And try to remember a time
when you were on fire.
On fire, lit up, excited
about being an entrepreneur.
See that's gone right?
"Yeah Grant, I'm burnt out.
That's what I'm telling you."
No, no, no, no.
Go back to the time when
you were lit up on fire.
You couldn't sleep at night.
You didn't need to eat okay?
All you needed was the idea of a future
you had for this dream, this idea
this business, whatever.
See at that time you were goal driven.
The possibilities were enormous.
They fed you.
You were mission driven.
See, it's when the mission's missing.
It's when the mission goes away
that a person starts to
experience being tapped out.
Or burned out.
Or exhausted.
At least this is my experience.
Look, when I'm not tapped
fully into my future.
My goals, the potential,
the possibilities.
I don't care what the job is.
Whether it was me when I
was working at McDonalds
or the Country Club.
I was working on a rig
down in the Gulf of Mexico
or whether I was writing my first book.
Look, when your goals aren't big enough.
When you're no longer sold on your vision
your purpose, your mission.
The symptoms of losing interest,
what many call burn out.
Burn outs are experienced.
Any time you start reaching
for massive success
the next thing.
You start settling in.
Getting comfortable.
Listen, settle to settle.
"Oh I just want to settle down."
Dude, why don't you just decide
to hate your life every day?
See, that's when you
start having problems.
When you start settling.
That's why comfort and complacency
are the entrepreneur's worst enemy.
In fact, I would tell you this.
The comfort and complacency
are everybody's worst enemy.
The only time I've ever
gotten in trouble in my life
was when I was bored, complacent.
When I was settling.
Who wants average?
Who wants average? Nobody wants it okay?
Nobody, no matter where you're at in life
you don't want average.
But we're surrounded by
average people every day.
Average ideas, average products.
Average advertising.
Only those that have given up on greatness
would settle for average.
Hey I want to talk to
you today about success.
Success, duty, obligation, responsibility.
If you approach it any other way
which most people are.
Most people think,
"Well I'll be successful
"If the economy works.
"I'll be successful if something happens.
"I'll be successful if I
win the lottery ticket."
Look, you're not going to be successful
if you don't demand it.
If you literally don't
stake a claim to it and say
"This is mine, it's important."
You're not going to
have it, I promise you.
I know, I'm telling you from experience.
I spent the first 25 years of my life
like a spectator.
Watching other people get successful
and then wondering why I wasn't.
Success is your duty.
It is your responsibility.
I'm sorry, your obligation
and your responsibility.
It's important.
You know, I mean there's so many mistakes
sales people make.
I think you need to get
down to like, the main ones.
But you're not selling the solution.
Even before that though,
I would say Corrine.
It's the biggest mistake,
people are not excited.
They're not alive.
They're not showing interest in the cycle
and they lose interest.
I was in Barcelona recently
and I was looking at a watch
and the cycle didn't close.
I could have bought the watch.
I was qualified to buy the watch.
I'm the one that walked myself
in the shop on my vacation
to look at the watch.
I knew exactly the
watch I was looking for.
And when I left my wife said
"What could he have
done to close the sale?"
I said well he could have
kept life in the cycle.
He could have kept the cycle open.
So what I mean by that is
look, if you're not interested.
If you don't believe
the cycle can be closed
it will not close.
So the number one mistake
I think sales people
managers and the store makes
is they assume a close
can't be had that day.
I go into every cycle.
Every sales cycle with every
prospect, every phone call.
Every, no matter how complex the sale is
or how simple it is
with the belief that I can
sell that product that day.
This time, now.
My message to you this week.
Right now is not the time to stop.
You can't stop.
I wake up this morning and I'm like
my God man what's going on,
what's happening to the world?
Place is coming, you know
it's a scary place to live in.
And I'm like, dude what are you doing?
You're stopping right now.
Now is not the time to stop or worry
or back up or become apathetic.
Now is the time to start again.
That's right, again.
It's like I've got to start over and over.
I've got to continue every day like you do
to improve yourself.
Improve your skills, improve your game.
Every day start over.
Now is not the time to
start or back up or retreat
or get lost in all the problems.
Look, you've got to assume right now
that you can do way more, way more
than you're doing.
Ask yourself this question.
I ask myself this probably
five times a week.
Now, what is my potential?
Is my potential greater than
what I'm delivering now?
Regardless of what people think
about my achievements or
my lack of achievements.
Whatever the case is.
I've been on both ends of this thing
where people were disappointed with me
early on in my life.
And also today when people are like
"Man, how do you get so much done?"
Neither one of those should
be where you're living.
It should be what is my potential?
What is your potential?
Have you fulfilled that potential?
Can you do more? Can
you make more contacts?
This is the model that we need to provide
for one another.
For our kids, for our parents
for everyone in our community.
Look, don't look for others to do this.
They're not.
Look around you
and what you see is average everywhere.
Average has become an epidemic.
You don't have people living
up to their potential.
You have people doing almost nothing.
People retreating, back up.
People that are lazy.
People that have checked out.
People that are waiting
for handouts and crumbs
and think that will give them security.
Look, now is the time to start again.
Your security, your family's security.
Your future is left in your hands.
Your destiny is yours.
Not someone else's.
Nobody else can do for you.
Nobody else can do it for me.
It's your job and my time.
Now is the time, now is the time to start.
Now is the time to start again.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know what did
you take from this video
that you're going to immediately apply
to your life or to your business.
What was the most important
lesson that you learned?
Please leave it down
in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Simon Stanley.
Simon, thank you do much
for picking up a copy
of my book Your One Word.
And making that awesome review
on your Youtube channel.
I really, really appreciate the support
and I'm glad you enjoyed the book.
- What's good guys?
Simon Stanley here
and in this video, I'm
doing a video review
of Your One Word, by Evan Carmichael.
- So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you continue
to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- Well, when I was 16
I started using drugs
and when I was 25 I was using drugs
15 times a day.
And I tried to quit for nine years.
Every day for nine years man.
So, then I went to a treatment center.
Because my mom's like, "Hey
don't even come around."
Everybody gave up on me.
Like everybody, this isn't some kind
of pulling hearts story.
This is like, dude people hated me man.
Okay, and the worst part of it
is I hated me.
So, it wasn't that.
I was broke, I didn't
have a job, all of that.
All the bad stuff but
the feeling that I had
about myself you know?
Was just awful.
So I went to the
treatment center you know?
And got off the drugs, quit
using drugs for 25 days
and they told me I had to leave
because the insurance was over.
What a scam that is.
And the councilor dude, I
don't even remember his name
but he told me on the way out, he's like
"Hey man, let me tell you something."
Because see, I don't know if you've ever
gone into one of these
12 step kind of deals
but you go in and you do like
this huge introspection on yourself
and then you've got to
share with the group
all your stuff.
So I'm telling these guys
that I want to be rich
and I think I'm James Bond
and I'm the reincarnation
of James Bond and you know.
(laughs)
I'm going to write books dude,
I'm going to be famous man
and people are going to see me
and I'm going to do all this.
Well, every time you do that over there
they're like, "No, no dude.
"Give up on the ego.
"Give up on grandiosity.
"You're not going to be rich.
"If you just don't use
drugs one day at a time
"Then you need to be happy."
And the guy told me on
the way out of the place.
He's like, "Look, if you
don't give up on all that
"You'll never make it."
And I walked out of there and said
"Dude, I'm going to get rich.
"I'm going to get rich,
I'm going to get famous."
Because dude, I just couldn't live a life
of just not doing drugs.
Because I don't think
drugs was my problem.
You know, it was just a
symptom of something else
that went awry.
And so, when I went back
I took that addictive, that
you know 15 times a day
and not trying to use drugs dude.
I took that energy
and I threw it in work.
And you know how I am at work
dude, I'm a maniac you know?
So, I took it
and I basically, people started telling me
"You just replaced one addiction
with another addiction."
And I'm like, "Yeah,
that's exactly what I did."
I replaced one addiction with another one.
And now I get addicted to
the good things in my life.
The negativity is just negative.
And there's no money in
it, there's no future
in being negative.
Where's the solution you know?
"I can't do that, we can't do that.
"That can't happen, this is wrong.
"That's wrong, oh my
gosh taxes are too high.
"Taxes are too."
Dude, it's negative.
It is negative.
It is negative!
Look, there's so much
abundance of negativity.
That by itself tells you
why there's no value in it.
I hear a lot of people
talk about one purpose
and one thing you know?
One thing has never filled me up.
Whether it was one friend,
one drug, whatever dude.
One doesn't work for me.
One wife is good, that's all I need.
I love my kids, one family you know.
But I've always needed something else.
You know, I need something
else to fill me up you know?
And it was, I'm 35 years old
and these people are
like, "Dude when are you
"Ever going to be satisfied?"
I heard that a lot.
When's enough enough?
You know?
Whey can't you just enjoy what you have?
Like something was wrong with me.
And I bought it, I bought those ideas.
I talk about this in the book
about feeding the beast and starving fear.
And I kept hearing about this you know.
"Well you're never going to be satisfied."
"Nothing fills you up
"And that's why you're so disappointed."
And people would say things like
"Don't have high expectations."
You know, Sam Walton
said the only way to live a
life is with high expectations.
The only way to achieve anything
is with high expectations.
But something happened in
America between 1980 and 2000
where everybody started
doing this introspection
feel your feelings.
What's the chick's name
over at Steve Carles place?
The coach over there?
- [Evan] Terry?
- No the one that says go
inside of, what was her name?
And I used her one time and
I said dude I can't do this.
Because it's just not who I am.
Like, I've done so much introspection
that I couldn't do anything.
I had to come and mobilize my purposes.
I mean, what's wrong with somebody
that wants to do another thing?
You know, look I am not
fueled up by one person.
My wife cannot fill me up.
Two kids can't make me feel full
because I think if people are obsessed
with a lot of purposes
and that's why people are dissatisfied.
And my goal is that this book
gives people permission to be.
To not be so introspective
but to actually become
obsessed with dreams again.
With possibilities.
With the idea that you could be a husband
a father, a community leader
a church leader, you could
actually talk about politics.
You could get rich.
You could write books.
You could find time to do all that
and not even worry about balance.
Because the obsession of
each one of those things
would actually fill you up
to have a life that
was naturally balanced.